[Music]
so I decided to prepare this game to
show you it's my game played actually
here at the Chess Club and one of my
latest tournaments here the spring
Classic Tournament which I managed to
win and in a in May and this is the game
against Grand Master from Argentina
Morocco 26 50 or 60 rating and I'm
playing with the black pieces here d4 d5
c4 e6 so right away we know the opening
great what opening is this yes
Queens gambit declined so Knight f3
Knight f6 g3 in that tournament Geoffrey
song has well played this g3 move
against me so I had two games this
opening in the same tournament so I
played Bishop before check I like
playing this move forcing Bishop b2 and
then go back to e7 the point of this
idea Bishop before check Bishop d2
Bishop goes back to his 7 is the Bishop
is on the 2 is misplaced so that's why I
cannot do anything so now Bishop g2
castles castles
Knight bd7 it's it's more accurate to
start out with 9b d7 because in some
point like if you play a move like 93 I
might be able just to capture the pawn
and just try to defend it that using
that extra option of night goes to b6
instead of playing c6 years or c6 is a
move here as well but 9b d7 is a more
precise move so he played the move Queen
c2 Knight e4 this is a new idea usually
black plays the move c6 years but 94
activating the bishop and putting
pressure on the two if we take a bishop
that will be good maybe we had a pair of
the mr. Bishop f4 is logical c6 Knight
c3 this position has been played several
times it's very fashionable nowadays my
ability to was played by pavel le on off
strong ukrainian grandmaster so i think
i think in the game against Crossin g5
Bishop III 96 was played and the point
of the night goes back on a5 and takes
the bishop carlson who won that game so
bishop only 3 is misplaced because of
that so that's why 93 is a better move
g5 anyway it looks bit you know more
aggressive than it should be but it's
interesting setup so Bishop Savannah had
so this position was also played in a US
Championship this year between
Wesley so and Hikaru Nakamura and there
were some other games played black gets
to push the Palin g5 fi but it's hard to
say whether or not you know this because
it could be also weak this paths could
be also weak you know so you cannot push
when you push the pants forward they
create weaknesses so my opponent played
b3 now he just wants to develop the
bishop on b2
I play b6 to develop my bishop in 92 is
the move that I didn't quite expect I
was expecting more when opponent plays
b3 normally you just put the bishop on
b2 but here he played 92 interesting
idea you know at some point he wants to
play a three also I have to calculate
the capture capture and then f3 so I had
to calculate a lot of things here and I
didn't like the fact that he can take my
knight and you know have some f3 ideas
there so I decided to take myself Knight
xe3
Queen takes c3 Knight f6 we exchange one
pair of knights I still have the control
of the e4 square which is very important
in this kind of structures and now I'm
planning to play the move Bishop d7 my
opponent played Bishop b2 and I play
Bishop d7 developing yes
because I worry about ecigs
being weak so that's the main reason and
now he played the mood okay see Juan but
he was very unhappy afterwards when we
were analyzing the game and basically
for the rest of the game he was not
happy about his position because now I
have a very strong move that he missed
and he should have done something better
because now this move is gonna make one
of his pieces very bad for the rest of
the game let's see if you can find a
move that I'm talking about black to
play what is the strong move here to get
the initiative here immediately after
this move I felt good about my position
and the rest of the game was pretty
smooth and he was not happy and not
comfortable because of this move
c5 pawn if you don't really want to play
c5 because it will open up the diagonal
see he has a queen and a bishop here and
he will take DC and open up everything
here so you don't wanna in this kind of
positions you want to keep it closed you
don't necessarily want to open the
position when opponent has to fianchetto
right when he has the fianchetto so we
don't want to open the position so we
want to keep it closed that way his
bishops are gonna be less effective
again it's a restricting move you're
trying to restrict one of his pieces
here that it's but what is a5 do what
pieces are restricting it be 585 they're
more like you trying to grab space but
here it's all about trying to restrict
that particular piece to achieve his
goal Bravo
correct g4 exclamation mark it stops the
knight from coming to f3 ever and then
he's gonna have a hard time getting only
5 imagined to get here now he has to
make so many moves Knight B one night 83
92 91 I did 3 to reach here he has to
make 5 moves to get there so one
careless move here you should to play
Knight f3 here one careless move here
and after g4 I thought more composition
is still fairly equal here but I felt
more comfortable about my chances here
now he played f3 now he played the f3
putting pressure a little bit and now I
knew that he is trying to play the move
efore at some point so what do we do now
absolutely try so if he captures we can
take back with a pawn he cannot play E
for here because we can take on f3 and
attack the bishop so something like this
it's not going to be good because we
just take hitting the bishop
Bishop captures we can take only force
so it's not good
so if they Bishop to h1 I think he's so
focused about playing this efore that
you know perhaps he didn't make the best
decisions here that and now
well he's gonna play you for dough I
mean if you move the night to h7 how are
you gonna how are you gonna deal with
this then this actually could work out
not well for him because let's say you
take he can take take take take and I
mean he just d5 is hanging hy-vee saying
and everything is hanging so the night
has to stay there
you know a5 it is an option I don't know
if yeah we'll just pay a tree and
prevent your Bishop before idea usually
this kind of moves you have to think you
know you push they will see something
that you're threatening so they will try
to prevent you how you gonna try to deal
with this efore move because e4 is
coming we need to do something guys to
to loosen him up a little bit you know
so they get that King a little bit more
loosened here now
absolutely correct
h4 yes absolutely because now you're
threatening to take on g3 weaken his
position and if he takes for example you
can play the move Bishop d6 and that's
not looking too good for him on h2 and
his King is very exposed so he played
the move Queen d3 he didn't want to take
once again I want to point out if you
take here I could play the move Bishop
d6 and the King is very very weak here
and h4 pawn likely to fall soon so he
played you're gonna see that's that's
what happened that's what happened
you're gonna see like in a few moves so
Bishop d3 so we we loosen him up right
and now which piece is not active that
we can activate here
ab-absolutely but first rook f7 that is
also not an active piece here right so I
want to be able to reroute him okay and
also I do this because in some cases if
it jumps in here I don't want him to
check me and force me to go to h8 that
dangerous you can get made it on h8 here
if it checks me ever I'm gonna have the
move rook to e7 now you will see in this
game war I managed to achieve as I his
both bishops were really bad and that's
what really helped me in this game she
played rook F 2 and now next few moves
I'm just trying to improve my pieces
take first so this was the final mistake
for him actually his position is really
critical after the move rook F to here
this was the last chance you know to try
to close the position and but you know
playing with a white pieces you don't
want to just the meteor worse you know
and play some position and just suffer
to make a draw here he is worse I will
play here move up you know triple up my
rooks I mean I'm clearly better here but
he might be able to hold with some
bishop g1 III rook e1 I have found some
kind of defense he can do so he should
have done that but he played the rook f2
and this was an inaccurate move because
of which move it's very important you
don't give up on at the second chance
capture now if Knight captures Bishop
captures I always have 94 so yes take
back with this and now absolutely rook
g7 you attacked upon threatening to take
it so it goes Knight f1 and now we want
to force him to play the move f4 because
that will give our Knight an excellent
squares so how you think you can force
him to do that Bishop d6 activating the
Bishop f4 pawn you can but then he plays
g4 and the pressure will be gone sort of
so this way you'd want to take so he
played a move f4 he could have played
Luke 3 to but I have tonight h5 he is
gonna be forced to
play a four anyways so he played after a
four and now let's see what is the idea
here you think yeah but the King needs
to be moved first right to be able to
put the rooks on a G file so I start
with king f7 he goes rook e1 and now
look at this coin g8 immediately putting
pressure on this I'm trying to move the
rook up and then triple up see this is
another moment here where you might be
stuck because you don't see anything
concrete so that's where you have to
pause and think to try to find an idea
an idea is right here king f7 Queen g8
putting pressure on g3 because that's
the target this is why you know he's
gonna he's basically tied up to this
defense so I play Bishop c1 back he's
trying to move the rook away but then
always Bishop f4 so that's the purpose
of this month and now I would like to
put his rook on an uncomfortable square
so I play the move Knight h5 because now
I have threats to take and also on f4 so
he has to put the rook here which he did
and now
you know you want to bring that rook on
it from a to the game right but you
don't want to just put anywhere you want
to put it on a G file so Duke g6
I like this book because it protects is
six and now I can play clean g7 and put
the rook on g8 that's what I like to do
so he goes here rook to Queen g7 now
putting pressure on d4 as well now he's
got another problem here d4 pawn is
vulnerable he goes here and now you see
I have a lot of pressure on him he's
barely holding this on but he can he
cannot hold this position for too long
complete domination here so Bishop g2
and now the final idea let's see if you
can find so far he's still holding it I
got four attackers on it and he's got
one two three four he's got four
defenders on it but he can change that
how excellent Knight f6 now threatening
to play ninety four check and pick up
the pollen g3 he took now what is your
best recapture here he took
of course with the Sipan so you have
opportunities to go this way as well
okay it should be good opportunities at
some point to do that so he goes Queen a
six-night belongs where we know that
there from general we know at night
belongs in the middle of course and here
he resigned he resigned because if he
goes here King he want I actually can't
even take on d4 and if he goes here this
is interesting if he goes here because
he's still holding everything I can take
on g3 and win but I have another idea
here
you could publicly nigt but what about
the C file now can we do something on a
C file if it's something we lend
something on c3 here would be quite good
no noxee one that I think looks III
technically you know if it takes is just
a mate so he has to play something like
Bishop b2 to prevent that now okay we
can just start capturing here take
take just winning the bishop so yeah
after I played after he played Queen 86
94 my opponent resigned and it's quite
happy actually to win a good game like
this with the black pieces against such
a strong opponent that you know normally
you don't have so many chances with
black so this shows that you know the
opening you know I got a decent position
the opening but one move one moment he
delayed to play Knight f3 and that's it
he couldn't really do much after that so
let's do a layer over review of this
game that I want to make sure everybody
who is sitting here remember the moves
okay so and that way you can review this
one more time again this is my game
against grandmas America from Argentina
so g4 you just have to say my moves
black moves c4 so now we have again
Queens gambit declined opening as soon
as g3 play what is the name of this
system the white is playing Catalan
Catalonia's this is forcing the bishop
to come to this that's the whole point
to force the bishop to come to d2
continue
don't rush castle first safety be safety
before you attack remember right safety
before your attack now
excellent now you have some ideas to
take on c4 right very good Queen c2 and
this is the new idea excellent yes
attacking here c6 first g5 is actually a
blunder because he can take if you take
you lose this is you have to be careful
okay I mean you lose material and then
if you take he takes your queen and this
is not that great okay
c6 so you have to be careful but again
g5 just tighten it up tighten it up the
position first before you start that
okay when you start to do an attack on a
flank you have to try on the side you
have to try to make sure your center is
strong okay Center needs to be really
solid when you do things on a flank so
you can't just you know have a loose
Center and try to do things on a flank
that's not gonna be successful
okay so c6 he goes here and now Alex
now g5 now Center is solid so maybe that
game I mentioned was Bishop e3 not not
be 293 Bishop e3 96 the the alien of
course and game Bishop c1 and now when
you play g5 you have to play the next
move
absolutely if you don't play a5 the
whole g5 is just very bad so you have to
do that b3
excellent and now Morocco didn't play
the Bishop b2 move which I knew if it 92
this surprised me a little bit so I had
to think a little bit to understand
what's going on here what is it trying
to do
93 correct Knight f6 we should be - and
if you're playing with the white pieces
which movies think you should play here
absolutely you gotta get at night only 5
you know because with the pawn on g5
there is no guarantee you're gonna have
a chance to learn later he would've
loved to move this rook back and do that
but when you make a move you miss
something then it's very hard so here's
a very important move here to make sure
that night stays passive for the rest of
the game here is absolutely g4 my stars
you're pushing pawns it's not that
common you know often times it's
actually not good but here I just have
so much space and that night just looks
really bad on me - he needs a lot of
moves I like this idea because I can
also play h5 h4 and put pressure so
that's what I like this for so he played
f3 h5 Bishop h1h for going for the
attack to loosen up the position of
opponent's king queen d3
age takes H takes absolutely rook F -
and this is the moment he had to play
the move F for since like twice in this
game you know once he didn't play Knight
if he and now he just told me he just
didn't want to play a slightly worse
position for the rest of the game you
know he wanted to but now very quickly
he's gonna regret it because he could
have have a similar position without all
the G file pressure that I have and it
would have been a lot harder for me to
try to win so when your position is
worse sometimes you have to admit it and
live with it you know just you know try
to defend it but he went here and now
capture attack
right
don't rush don't rush don't rush it
should be six come on activate the
bishop activate a bishop and put
pressure on g3 now he goes f4 king f7
getting that g8 for our queen Queen g8
that's our target right
Ruka three rook g6 lifts up a little bit
to protect g6 and now you want to do
what do you want to do now triple up
triple up okay he goes here
absolutely rook g8 now putting pressure
on g3 the enormous pressure now for him
he cannot do anything here to hold this
so he goes Bishop g2 and now what you
gonna do now absolutely Knight f6
threatening 94th check he took I mean he
couldn't do anything so that's why he
just you know
yeah he could have played King g1 but 94
I win this pawn and game is just lost
because his pawns are just too weak but
this actually it plays into my hand
because now I have the bishop on b5 idea
and rook on c8 so continue check now he
has to go here
Rocsi eight attacking the bishop here
actually actually he resigned here it's
just to be officially resigned here if
he goes to you want it's just I take on
d4 and Bishop before is just a mate so
Luke c8 cake blends into a mate and
Bishop b2 just take this pawn there
might be other ways to win but this just
so that's the game against Morocco okay
very good so that's the game I have a
lot more games to show at some point now
I have one position for you at the end
of this lecture I want to have one
position for you to solve if you know
this position please let me know okay
it's very obviously white is completely
winning but the goal here is not just
the win we know you can win this the
goal here is to win this position in
three moves I just like the idea so much
white to play checkmate in three yeah
it's actually it's very useful to do
these positions because it it shows you
some new ideas that sometimes you don't
know or maybe you forgot so it was
really nice you know when I saw this so
let's think you have to take advantage
of the position of the King yeah that is
not very good here try to see the entire
solution yeah try to have the entire
solution if we have time I have another
one I can show you okay Queen e2
here
that's one
looks like he escapes your idea would've
work but it just escapes you have to try
to see what kind of moose he has black
has for legal moves black has for legal
moves right
- with the king at the moment he does he
has three moves but King move and the
pawn moves he has normally it's time to
check first for just just this in
general say no no but in this position
if you start with checking will be too
easy
check checkmate yeah I'll be Queen Queen
G one do you want
that's a deep idea what's the plan well
if if c5g to check travel but and the
alchemist I go here to here
unfortunately there are CSS escapes okay
you're I get c5 that idea works yes I
think you're getting closer right you're
understanding that you need a quick move
here King is fine
we need to find the right square okay
you need to find the right square and
you're gonna do it
it's your idea it's going to work then
if you find the right look it's gonna be
exact same checkmate like you point it
out between G to check 25 but you just
need the right square so you have
something to do when you place a 5 so
when you place if I mean create some key
pitch can see 5 escapes - okay you need
to make a move that when I take King if
I work in 85 you never made in one yeah
so make a move that when I move to keep
to see if I what if I can make one
aha we did you yes sir that's the first
move really yeah just here now what do
you do yeah it was here what are you
gonna do so anything else here what you
get to do you too
now we go back to dance idea right
that's your main then and now if you
place here let's see man 3 yeah you have
to see the symmetry without the court
you know with this move with this move
between V 2
that's exactly what you're going to
achieve you know you're going to be able
to achieve that symmetry if it was the
g5 you go clean g5 mate if it goes to c5
evil-lyn a pie plate if he pushes the
CEPA Queen g2 in g58 so once again if
you play c5 let's do this one more time
okay so let's go from beginning what's
the first move we do so if it was here
which check me if he goes here
check me so if it was here in g2
check if he goes here too that's the
idea okay
so it's just really beautiful idea and
it shows how this symmetry same symmetry
will work okay so that's that's the key
to understand and remember if you know
this idea that you know the symmetry
will work so you'll be able to solve lot
more positions okay
[Music]
you
[Music]